pretty simple stuff folks
these big political problems
that our opponents want to pretend are
so complicated oh well you know gender
and sex it's so it's not complicated men
or men and women are women well you know
the issue of reproductive freedom and
now it's not don't kill babies it's
really simple well the issue of
immigration is so complicated Ronald
Reagan said illegal immigration is not
complicated it's illegal stop it
crime is not complicated lock up the
criminals build more prisons lock them
up punish them harder you'll get less
crime
how do we have a great country look
toward God look to the source and Summit
of goodness himself being himself you'll
have a good country you look away from
God you're going to have a bad country
it's very very simple